--
(INDISCERNIBLE)
WE'RE EXCITED TO --
>> WONDERFUL AUTHORS WHO WILL
SHARE THEIR STORIES WITH US.
MS.
PAR TON'S WORK THROUGH HER
IMAGINATION LIBRARY IS ON FIRE.
SHE AND HER TEAM HAVE GIVEN AWAY
OVER 100 MILLION BOOKS TO HELP
TO ENCOURAGE YOUNG READERS LIKE
YOU ACROSS THE WORLD. HERE AT
THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS, WE
SHARE THAT PASSION FOR
DEVELOPING YOUNG LEADERS, AND WE
KNOW THAT THE BEST WAY TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE LIKE YOU TO
READ IS TO MAKE READING FUN. SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE TO DO.
I HOPE YOU ENJOY TODAY'S STORY
TIME. EVEN MORE, I HOPE YOU KEEP
READING AT HOME AND HAVING FUN.
TODAY, YOU WILL WARM UP BY
SINGING SOME
SONGS, TOUCHING YOUR TOES, AND
THEN GET COMFORTABLE AND GET
READY TO SEE A STORY. NOW LET'S
GET STARTED.
>> WELCOME, EVERYBODY, TO THE
LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FOR OUR SIXTH DOLLY
PARTON IMAGINATION LIBRARY STORY
TIME. WE'RE SO HAPPY YOU COULD
JOIN US AND YOU AT HOME. SO MY
NAME IS CAROLINE.
WE'RE GOING BE FEATURING TODAY,
SINCE
TOMORROW IS THE BEGINNING OF --
IS OUR ANNUAL NATIONAL BOOK
FESTIVAL, WE'RE
FEATURING TWO OF OUR AUTHORS,
MAGDA PENA.
BUT FIRST LET'S START WITH OUR
HELLO SONG. SO WE DO SOME SIGNS
WITH IT. SO THE SIGN FOR HELLO
IS YOU DO A LITTLE SALUTE.  YES?
AND THEN THE SIGN FOR FRIENDS,
WE'RE
GOING TO SING * HELLO, FRIENDS"
TO THE TUNE OF "GOOD NIGHT,
LADIES."  AND THE SIGNS FOR
FRIENDS IS YOU TAKE YOUR INDEX
FINGERS AND YOU HUG THEM ONE WAY
AND THEN THE OTHER WAY.
AND THEN IT'S TIME, YOU'RE GOING
TO TOUCH YOUR IMAGINATION WATCH.
AND THEN TO SAY -- YOU TOUCH
YOUR MOUTH. AND THEN HELLO.
* HELLO, FRIENDS * * HELLO,
FRIENDS * * HELLO, FRIENDS * *
IT'S TIME TO SAY HELLO *
>> ONE MORE TIME.
* HELLO, FRIENDS * * HELLO,
FRIENDS * *
HELLO FRIENDS * * IT'S TIME TO
SAY HELLO *  GREAT JOB.  OKAY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
LET'S DO OUR CLASSIC OPEN TO
WAKE UP THE BRAIN.
* OPEN SHUT THEM OPEN SHUT THEM
* * GIVE A LITTLE CLAP CLAP CLAP
* * OPEN SHUT
THEM OPEN SHUT THEM * * PUT THEM
IN YOUR
LAP LAP LAP *  * CREEP AND CRAWL
AND
CREEP AND CRAWL * * AND RIGHT UP
TO YOUR
CHIN CHIN CHIN * * OPEN UP YOUR
LITTLE
MOUTH * * BUT DO NOT LET THEM IN
* ONE
MORE TIME * * OPEN SHUT THEM
OPEN SHUT THEM * * GIVE A LITTLE
CLAP CLAP CLAP *
* OPEN SHUT THEM OPEN SHUT THEM
*  * PUT
THEM IN YOUR LAP LAP LAP *
* GREET THEM CREEP AND CRAWL AND
CREEP AND CRAWL * * AND RIGHT UP
TO YOUR CHIN
CHIN CHIN * * OPEN UP YOUR
LITTLE MOUTH
* * BUT DO NOT LET THEM IN **
GOOD JOB.  ALL RIGHT.
SO, WELCOME OUR FIRST AUTHOR.
MAGDA DE PENA TO COME UP AND
READ HIS BOOK, "LAST STOP ON
MARKET STREET."
OKAY.  HERE WE GO.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> HELLO, GUYS, HOW YOU DOING?
>> GREAT.
>> I'M EXCITED TO READ TO YOU
FROM LAST STOP ON MARKET STREET.
CJ PUSHED THROUGH THE CHURCH
DOORS AND SKIPPED DOWN THE
STEPS.
THE OUTSIDE AIR SMELLED LIKE
FREEDOM, BUT IT ALSO SMELLED
LIKE RAIN, WHICH FRECKLED CJ'S
SHIRT AND DRIPPED DOWN HIS NOSE.
HE DUCKED UNDER HIS IN A IN A'S
UMBRELLA SAYING, HOW COME WE GOT
TO WAIT
FOR THE BUS IN ALL OF THIS WET?
TREES GET THIRSTY TOO, HIS IN A
IN A TOLD HIM? DON'T YOU SEE
THAT BIG ONE DRINKING THROUGH A
STRAW?
CJ LOOKED FOR A LONG TIME, BUT
NEVER SAW A STRAW.
AND BY THE WAY, IF YOU'RE A
LITTLE GUY, IF YOU CAN SEE THE
STRAW THAT THAT TREE IS DRINKING
FROM, THEN YOU UNDERSTAND THE
ENTIRE BOOK.
BUT WE WON'T GET INTO THAT NOW.
FROM THE BUS STOP, HE WATCHED
WATER POOL ON FLOWER PETALS,
WATCHED RAIN PATTER AGAINST THE
WINDSHIELD OF A NEARBY CAR.
HIS FRIEND, COLBY CLIMBED IN,
GAVE CJ A WAVE, AND DROVE OFF
WITH HIS DAD.
IN A IN A, HOW COME WE DON'T
HAVE A CAR?
WHAT DO WE NEED A CAR FOR? WE
HAVE A BUS THAT BREATHES FIRE
AND OLD MR.
DENNIS WHO ALWAYS HAS A TRICK
FOR YOU. THE BUS CREEPED TO A
STOP IN FRONT OF THEM.
IT SIGHED AND SAGGED AND THE
DOORS SWUNG OPEN. WHAT'S THAT I
SEE, MR.
DENNIS ASKED?
HE PULLED A COIN FROM BEHIND
C.J.
'S EAR, PLACED IT IN HIS PALM.
IN A IN A LAUGHED HER DEEP LAUGH
AND PUSHED C.J. ALONG.
THEY SAT RIGHT UP FRONT, WHICH,
BY THE WAY, IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT LINES IN THE BOOK AND
NOBODY REALLY TALKS ABOUT IT.
THE MAN ACROSS THE WAY WAS
TUNING A GUITAR. AN OLD WOMAN
WITH CURLERS HAD BUTTERFLIES IN
A JAR.
IN A IN A GAVE EVERYONE A GREAT
BIG SMILE AND A GOOD AFTERNOON.
SHE MADE SURE CJ DID THE SAME.
THE BUS LURCHED FORWARD,
STOPPED, LURCHED FORWARD,
STOPPED. NANA HUMMED AS SHE
KNIT.
HOW COME WE HAVE TO GO AFTER
CHURCH, CJ SAID. MIGUEL AND
COLBY NEVER HAVE TO GO NOWHERE.
I FEEL SORRY FOR THOSE BOYS, SHE
TOLD HIM, THEY'LL NEVER GET A
CHANCE TO BEAT
BOBO AND THE SUP GLASS MAN, AND
I HEAR
TRICKSY GOT HERSELF A BRAND NEW
HAT. CJ STARED OUT THE WINDOW
FEELING SORRY FOR HIMSELF.
HE WATCHED CARS ZIP BY ON EITHER
SIDE, WATCHED A GROUP OF BOYS
HOP CURBS ON BIKES.
A MAN CLIMBED ABOARD WITH A
SPOTTED DOG. CJ GAVE UP HIS
SEAT. HOW COME THAT MAN CAN'T
SEE? BOY, WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT
SEEING, HIS NANA TOLD HIM? SOME
PEOPLE WATCH THE WORLD WITH
THEIR EARS.  THAT'S A FACT.
THEIR NOSES TOO, THE MAN SAID,
SNIFFING AT THE AIR.
SOME MIGHTY FINE PERFUME YOU'RE
WEARING TODAY, MA'AM.
NANA SQUEEZED THE MAN HAND AND
LAUGHED HER DEEP LAUGH.
TWO OLDER BOYS GOT ON NEXT. CJ
WATCHED AS THEY MOVED ON BY, AND
STOOD IN BACK.
SURE WISH I HAD ONE OF THOSE, HE
SAID, AND IF YOU CAN'T SEE IN
THE BACK, THEY'RE LISTENING TO
HEADPHONES, THEY PROBABLY HAVE
AN IPHONE OR AN iPOD.
NANA SAT DOWN HER KNITTING.
BY THE WAY, IF YOUR GRANDMOTHER
SITS DOWN HER KNITTING, YOU KNOW
YOU MIGHT BE IN TROUBLE.  WHAT
FOR? YOU'VE GOT THE REAL LIVE
THING SITTING ACROSS FROM YOU.
WHY DON'T YOU ASK THE MAN IF
HE'LL PLAY US A SONG. CJ DIDN'T
HAVE TO. THE GUITAR PLAYER WAS
ALREADY PLUCKING STRINGS AND
BEGINNING TO SING.
TO FEEL THE MAGIC OF MUSIC, THE
BLIND MAN WHISPERED, I LIKE TO
CLOSE MY EYES.
NANA CLOSED HER'S TOO. SO DID CJ
AND THE SPOTTED DOG.
THEN THE DARKNESS, THE RHYTHM
LIFTED CJ OUT OF THE BUS, OUT OF
THE BUSY CITY. HE SAW SUNSET
COLORS SWIRLING OVER CRASHING
WAVES, SAW A FAMILY OF HAWKS
SLICING THROUGH THE SKY. HE SAW
THE OLD WOMAN'S BUTTERFLIES
DANCING FREE IN THE LIGHT OF THE
MOON.
CJ'S CHEST GREW FULL AND HE WAS
LOST IN THE SOUNDS AND THE SOUND
GAVE HIM THE FEELING OF MAGIC.
THE SONG ENDED AND CJ OPENED HIS
EYES, EVERYONE ON THE BUS
CLAPPED. EVEN THE BOYS IN BACK.
NANA GLANCED AT THE COIN IN CJ'S
PALM, CJ DROPPED IT IN THE MAN'S
HAT. LAST STOP ON MARKET STREET,
MR. DENNIS CALLED.
CJ LOOKED AROUND AS HE STEPPED
OFF OF
THE BUS, CRUMBLING SIDEWALKS,
BROKEN
DOWN DOORS, GRAFFITI TAGGED
WINDOWS AND BOARDED UP STORES,
HE REACHED FOR HIS NANA'S HAND.
HOW COME IT'S ALWAYS SO DIRTY
OVER HERE. SHE MILED AND POINTED
TO THE SKY,
SOMETIMES, WHEN YOU'RE
SURROUNDED BY DIRT, CJ, YOU'RE A
BETTER WITNESS FOR WHAT'S
BEAUTIFUL.
CJ SAW THE PERFECT RAINBOW
ARCING OVER THEIR SOUP KITCHEN.
HE WONDERED HOW HIS NANA ALWAYS
FOUND BEAUTIFUL WHERE HE NEVER
EVEN THOUGHT TO LOOK.
HE LOOKED ALL AROUND THEM AGAIN
AT THE BUS ROUNDING THE CORNER,
OUT OF SIGHT. AND THE BROKEN
STREET LAMPS STILL LIT UP
BRIGHT. AND THE STRAY SHADOWS
MOVING ACROSS THE WALL.
WHEN HE SPOTTED THEIR FAMILIAR
FACES IN THE WINDOW, HE SAID,
I'M GLAD WE CAME.
HE THOUGHT HIS NANA MIGHT LAUGH
HER DEEP LAUGH, BUT SHE DIDN'T.
SHE PATTED HIM ON THE HEAD AND
TOLD HIM, ME TOO, CJ.
NOW, COME ON, AND THE LAST PAGE
YOU SEE, CJ AND HIS GRANDMOTHER,
THEY'RE AT THE SOUP KITCHEN, BUT
THEY'RE NOT THERE TO EAT,
THEY'RE THERE TO SERVE.
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH FOR
LETTING ME READ TO YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WONDERFUL, THANK YOU. WHAT A
WONDERFUL BOOK ABOUT COMMUNITY
AND FINDING VALUE IN THE LITTLE
THINGS IN LIFE. AND IN GIVING,
YES?  ALL RIGHT.
SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO DO AN
ADAPTION OF "WHEELS ON THE BUS"
THAT OUR PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AT THE YOUNG READER
CENTER AND I WROTE. SO, LOOK AT
YOUR PROGRAMS.
* LALALALALA LALALA LALALA * *
LALALALALALALALA * * LALALALALA
* * THE
WHEELS IN THE BUS GO ROUND AND
ROUND ROUND AND ROUND * * THE
WHEELS ON THE BUS GO ROUND AND
ROUND ALL THROUGH THE
TOWN *
* THE OH NANA ON THE BUS GOES
KNIT KNIT
KNIT, KNIT KNIT KNIT * * OH NANA
ON THE
BUS GOES KNIT KNIT KNIT * * ALL
THROUGH
THE TOWN *  * CJ ON THE BUS HE
LOOKS AND LISTENS LOOKS AND
LISTENS LOOKS AND
LISTENS * * CJ ON THE BUS HE
LOOKS AND
LISTENS ALL THROUGH THE TOWN *
* THE
DOG ON THE BUS GOES SNIFF SNIFF
SNIFF *
* SNIFF SNIFF SNIFF * * SNIFF
SNIFF
SNIFF * * O THE DOG ON THE BUS
GOES SNIFF SNIFF SNIFF * * ALL
THROUGH THE TOWN * * THE
GUITARIST ON THE BUS GOES STRUM
STRUM STRUM STRUM STRUM STRUM
STRUM STRUM STRUM * * THE
GUITARIST ON
THE BUS GOES STRUM STRUM STRUM
* * ALL
THROUGH THE TOWN *  * O THE
PEOPLE ON THE BUS GO CLAP CLAP
CLAP CLAP CLAP CLAP
CLAP CLAP CLAP * * O THE PEOPLE
ON THE
BUS GO CLAP CLAP CLAP * * ALL
THROUGH
THE TOWN *
* ON THE DRIVER ON THE BUS SAYS
HERE'S YOUR STOP HERES YOUR STOP
HERE'S YOUR
STOP * * O THE DRIVER ON THE BUS
SAYS HERE'S YOUR STOP * * ON THE
END OF MARKET STREET *  [
APPLAUSE ]
ALL RIGHT.
SO LET'S
-- NOW WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
SECOND AUTHOR WHO'S GOING TO
READ HER PICTURE BOOK ON MATH.
>> HELLO.
>> THANK YOU.
>> HI, EVERYONE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I'M SO HONORED TO BE HERE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I'M GOING TO READ
ONE OF MY BOOKS
CALLED GOOD NIGHT, NUMBERS.
WRITTEN BY ME, DANICA McKELLER
AND
ILLUSTRATED BY ALICIA PATRON WHO
ILLUSTRATED ANOTHER BOOK I
CALLED BATH TIME MATH TIME. SHE
DOES GREAT
ILLUSTRATIONILLUSTRATIONS, SO
SWEET. HOW MANY OF YOU GUYS KNOW
HOW TO COUNT TO 10? ANYBODY
COUNT TO 10? YOU CAN? YEAH. I
KNOW MY SON CAN. I DEDICATED
THIS BOOK TO DRACO, THAT'S MY
SON. HE'S 7 AND HE'S SITTING
OVER THERE. YOU GUYS READY? SO
THIS IS A STORY ABOUT GETTING
READY FOR BED. IT SHOWS LOTS OF
DIFFERENT FAMILIES GETTING READY
FOR BED AND COUNTING ONE TO TEN
AS WE DO.
AND ON EACH PAGE, THERE'S LOTS
OF THINGS TO COUNT OF THAT
NUMBER. SO HERE WE GO.
ONE, GOOD NIGHT ONE FORK, GOOD
NIGHT ONE SPOON, GOOD NIGHT ONE
BOWL. I'LL SEE YOU SOON. WE'RE
FINISHING DINNER. WHAT DO YOU DO
AFTER DINNER? WASH YOUR HANDS,
RIGHT?
TWO. GOOD NIGHT TWO HANDS. GOOD
NIGHT TWO FEET. GOOD NIGHT TWO
EARS.  SO SMALL AND SWEET.
DO YOU GUYS HAVE TWO EARS? YOU
HAVE TWO EARS? YEAH? YOU HAVE
TWO HANDS?
ME TOO. THREE, WE'RE GOING TO
PUT AWAY OUR TOYS. GOOD NIGHT
THREE WHEELS.
THAT'S ON A TRICYCLETRICYCLE,
GOOD NIGHT THREE CANS.
THESE ARE GARBAGE CANS. MY SON
WAS LITTLE, HE LOVED PLAYING
WITH GARBAGE CANS. I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT YOU GUYS, BUT HE LOVED IT.
YOU DO? YEAH, THEY'RE FUN,
RIGHT?
GOOD NIGHT ALL TRUCKS AND POTS
AND PANS.
AND THIS, BY THE WAY, THIS IS
OUR DOGGY NAMED SPARTACUS. HE
LOVED OUR COUCH.
FOUR. NOW IT'S BATH TIME. GOOD
NIGHT FOUR PAWS ON THE CAT. GOOD
NIGHT, KITTY CAT.
GOOD NIGHT FOUR FROGGES ON THE
BATHROOM MAT.
YOU CAN SEE, THERE'S ONE, TWO,
THREE, FOUR. THERE'S OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE THERE ARE FOUR
OF TOO. FOUR BUTTONS ON THE
CUSHION. THERE ARE FOUR LITTLE
BUBBLES HERE IN THIS PICTURE.
NOW WE'RE IN THE BATH. FIVE.
GOOD NIGHT FIVE POINTS. GOOD
NIGHT LITTLE STAR. GOOD NIGHT
FIVE SPLASHES. THEY GO REALLY
FAR. DO YOU GUYS EVER SPLASH IN
THE TUB?
PROBABLY A LOT MORE THAN FIVE
SPLASHES, RIGHT?  YEAH, SIX.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO GET OUR PJ'S
ON, OUR PAJAMAS. GOOD NIGHT SIX
SNAPS. SNAP THAT UP. GOOD NIGHT
MR. PEACH. GOOD NIGHT SIX BLOCKS
WITH SIX SIDES EACH. YOU GUYS
HAVE BLOCKS? YOU EVER PLAY WITH
BLOCKS? THEY HAVE SIX SIDES TO
THEM.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO BRUSH OUR
TEETH. AND THIS IS A CALENDAR ON
THE WALL. YOU KNOW HOW MANY DAYS
THERE ARE IN A WEEK? YOU GUYS
KNOW? SEVEN. ALL RIGHT. SEVEN.
GOOD NIGHT SEVEN DAYS.  GOOD
NIGHT WHOLE WEEK.
GOOD NIGHT SEVEN TEETH SO CLEAN
THEY SQUEAK. YOU GUYS HAVE SEVEN
TEETH YET?  YEAH?  NO.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO CLIMB INTO
BED. STORY TIME FOR NUMBER
EIGHT. HOW MANY ARMS DOES AN
OCTOPUS HAVE? YOU GUYS KNOW?
HOW MANY ARMS DOES AN OCTOPUS
HAVE?
EIGHT?  YES.  GOOD NIGHT, EIGHT
ARMS.  GOOD NIGHT TALL VINE.
GOOD NIGHT EIGHT SIDES ON THE
RED STOP SIGN.  YOU GUYS EVER
SEEN A STOP SIGN?  YEAH, YOU'VE
SEEN IT?
YOU HAVE EIGHT SIDES.
CALLED AN OCTAGON.  ALL RIGHT,
NOW WE'RE GOING TO GET INTO BED.
NINE --
AND THERE'S A LITTLE -- THERE'S
A LITTLE MOBILE HERE WITH NINE
BUTTERFLIES ON IT. GOOD NIGHT
NINE BUTTERFLIES. GOOD NIGHT
NINE BARS.
GOOD NIGHT TO THE MOON AND THE
COUNTLESS STARS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER THINGS
ON EACH PAGE. NINE SPOTS RIGHT
HERE. NINE SQUARES. THERE'S NINE
STARS. SO YOU CAN SEE.  ALL
RIGHT.  ANYBODY GUESS THE LAST
NUMBER?  YEAH?  TEN. YES.
ALL RIGHT, NOW WE'RE GETTING
TUCKED IN.
TEN -- GOOD NIGHT TEN FINGERS.
DO YOU HAVE TEN FINGERS? YEAH?
YEAH.
GOOD NIGHT TEN FINGERS, GOOD
NIGHT TEN TOES.
GOOD NIGHT TO THE WORLD AND
EVERYONE KNOWS.
THAT NUMBERS ARE AROUND US, LIKE
REALLY GOOD FRIENDS.
GOOD NIGHT TO ALL THE NUMBERS,
GOOD NIGHT AND THE END.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> WONDERFUL INTRODUCTION TO
MATH. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S DO ONE, TWO BUCKLE MY
SHOE. YOU REMEMBER THAT, DON'T
YOU?
SO WE'RE GOING TO DO SOME
GESTURES. WE'RE GOING TO TOUCH
OUR TOES.
ONE, TWO, BUCKLE MY SHOE. THREE,
FOUR, SHUT THE DOOR.
FIVE, SIX, PICK UP STICKS.
SEVEN, EIGHT, LAY THEM STRAIGHT.
OH, I THINK I MISSED -- LET'S
SEE,
ANKLES, KNEES, HIPS -- NINE, 10,
BEGIN AGAIN.  ONE, TWO, BUCKLE
MY SHOE.
THREE, FOUR, SHUT THE DOOR.
FIVE, SIX, PICK UP STICKS.
SEVEN, EIGHT, LAY THEM STRAIGHT.
NINE, TEN, AND THEN THE SECOND
TIME WE DO -- BIG FAT HEN!
BIG FAT HEN. OKAY.
I THINK I MESSED UP THE ANKLES,
KNEES
--
HIPS, SO SEVEN, EIGHT, LAY THEM
STRAIGHT. OKAY, 1, 2, BUCKLE MY
SHOE. 3, 4, SHUT THE DOOR.
5, 6, PICK UP STICKS.
7, 8, LAY THEM STRAIGHT. 9, 10,
DO IT AGAIN. 1, 2, BUCKLE MY
SHOE.
3, 4, SHUT THE DOOR. 5, 6, PICK
UP STICKS.
7, 8, LAY THEM STRAIGHT.
9, 10, BIG FAT HEN!
SORRY. I GOT MIXED UP.  ALL
RIGHT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE THE
GOOD
NIGHT THEME WITH A LITTLE SONG
OF THANKS.
AND IT'S BASED ON BRAHAM'S LULL
BUY.  LULLABYE.
(HUMMING BRAHAM'S LULLABYE *
* LALALA LALALALALA * *
LALALALA * LALALALALALA *  * WE
GIVE
THANKS FOR THE EARTH * * FOR THE
DAY AND
THE NIGHT * * FOR THE STARS AND
THE MOON
* * AND THE SUN THAT GIVES US
LIGHT * *
FOR THE CLOUDS AND THE RAIN AND
THE
FIELDS FULL OF GRAIN * * FOR THE
LAND
AND THE SEA * AND THE FLOWERS
AND TREES *  [ APPLAUSE ]
OKAY, GOOD JOB!
ALL RIGHT.  SO THAT'S ALL WE
HAVE FOR TODAY.
AND IF YOU'RE IN THE AREA, DO
PLEASE COME TO THE NATIONAL BOOK
FESTIVAL.
IT'S A FABULOUS TIME ALL DAY
LONG AT THE WASHINGTON
CONVENTION CENTER.
ALL RIGHT, SO LET'S END WITH OUR
GOOD-BYE SONG, WHICH IS THE
OPPOSITE OF THE HELLO. AND TO
SAY GOOD-BYE, WE JUST SAY
GOOD-BYE.  RIGHT?
* GOOD-BYE, FRIENDS GOOD-BYE,
FRIENDS *
* * GOOD-BYE, FRIENDS * * IT'S
TIME TO
SAY GOOD-BYE *  SEE YOU AGAIN,
BYE-BYE!
[ APPLAUSE ]